alright so i just read that later today
President Obama is going to get three
year or at least try to get from
Congress three year war authorization to
fight the Islamic state also known as
Isis also known as I sell whatever you
want to call them a bunch of [ __ ]
that would be fine with me that's what
I'm going to call him for now on just
those [ __ ] [ __ ] that are
beheading people and burning people
doing all kinds of awful [ __ ] anyway we
are going to actually get war
authorization now you might think that's
odd seems like we've been fighting a war
with them right we're dropping bombs in
iraq now they're sort of they say that
that's because we had authorization from
the old iraq war because we know how
well that went so that's one thing but
we've been bombing syria along with
other nations but mostly us because it
always comes down to mostly else or
we're just very eager to do things i'm
not sure which is which but anyway we've
been there bombing syria for months
already months now I don't know that we
should be doing it I don't know that we
can help every time we bomb someone we
end up creating more people that hate us
we all know about all that stuff but I
think it's really interesting that it
took months months for to get war
authorization if we've been doing this
for a month and we're finally going to
get it now three years by the way we all
know that when they put a timetable on
thing that means absolutely nothing
President Obama won't even be President
in three years from now unless he goes
for the third term which I do think it's
a possibility that they're going to try
that but the thing is with the war
authorization he'll be gone and you
never know what's going to happen so did
we just start another one did it just
start I get there's other news going on
right now the jon stewart thing Brian
Williams thing but this is the most
important thing that's happening right
now we're about to authorize another war
that we've already been fighting without
authorization so it's really important
that we talk about this stuff and really
try to have some discussion as to what
our role in the world should be should
other countries be doing more you know
there was the horrible situation with
the Jordanian pilot who got burned alive
Jordan is now jumped in I just read that
they killed something like 7000 Isis
fighters in like three days or something
so what do all these nations have to do
what is our role in this we should have
a debate about it i hope we start having
a debate about it because we're not
really we're not good about having an
honest debate about what's going on
everyone was i'm completely against war
and everyone else is completely for war
I guess what that's just silly there's
some horrible [ __ ] going on in the world
maybe we have to be
part of the solution and and maybe we
don't but we should at least talk about
it so I'm glad that they're at least
getting authorization so that maybe
there'll be some discussion on what our
role should be